okay
starting out this stream
not with
viewer games but an hourly bullet arena
small crew in there to start 47
let's see what we get
gore lee 2013
in game one
all right satisfied so far
i imagine i'll need my c pawn
contributing i don't mind a queen
exchange or losing this guy it's what
i've
basically signed up for
when uh
bringing this bishop out and about
i want to take extra care over this
square
we'll keep the queens on now
try and address this uh
uh
that's i get the b pawn if they do that
seems like a pretty good square my queen
is not easily kicked
probably take with the knight i like the
knight on this square
pave the way for my king to improve
this knight is going to be extra
extra annoying let's try and reinforce
them
i think h4 is good
um
why'd i give that guy up
i should have given that guy up
got to get this minority attack going
oh i thought they would have captured
with the knight
like i'm close to getting mated
any forks
get rid of that night
gotta go for time burners
oh
oh i've done a time gourley
i need to do a much better job
in that ending without the queen that
should have been really sweet that
knight on f4
um
maybe
yeah that h4 move was a good
good start to undermine my night post
should have uh
maybe put my knight on
that other square d3 and then
and then work from there
okay
so not a good start
let's take and then get this break in
with d4
um
i'll go king's side
click on d1
d1e1
centralize for starters
let's try this
poke around some weaknesses
whoa
no support for that bishop that was a
that was a free bishop
i guess they're going for f6 break
that's the only way
make progress
improve my worst
minor take with the pawn i like this guy
around here
now h6 sensitive sneak into f6
triple up
all right we got a new square let's get
doubled first this bishop is staring off
into space
i could take here
okay
yeah i had
yeah i think well no
of course it was a lot easier when
you're up a piece but
i liked the uh
the king side play that i had
i played 2020
to be a little careful that night if
they played knight c3
had to be a little careful
all right uh all right we'll go for a
dark exchange
no pin anymore i'm okay with pulling the
bishop away
i want to stop a quick
night 95 knight f3 thing
actually not okay
not prepared for b4 yet
queen on b6 is pretty useful
i'll take that
weaken some dark squares i'm on this f4
square again
uh i'll take the palm
i guess we'll get the break in minority
is rolling
i would not mind exchanges knight
exchange
have the file the only open file
i'm off of it now
but i want to protect the b-pawn let's
get the queens off if we can
oh
that was a mess
go hunting for pawns mon f2
that's the one i really want
uh let's keep control the back rank i
don't even want to allow rook check
knight f8 stuff
take some pawns with check
all right no no stalemates
there we go
okay where are we at here oh there's
over 100 now
in there where am i at where am i at
page one barely
hat one two threes in first talent
second
okay
opponent i've played many times
20 minutes remaining
these fly by
that's an unusual start i normally i
think my opponent normally plays c5
mixing it up a little a little bit
good opponent
good and fast
break the pin i guess they're going for
e5 i may have to go back let's see mass
exchange is
ensuing go right here
okay i don't think i okay queen d3 i'll
i'll just go back
yeah i need to be able to castle
or going castle didn't have the queens
off my king is ideally placed
for this
ensuing center i want to keep some
material on i don't want it to just turn
into a night game
um i don't know though you know that
night is actually pretty pesky
try to offset him it's not easy though
it's getting in there
yeah there is a checaroni
the other knight is
very good
and now i'm wishing
i
didn't play it like this
um
yeah
oh boy
just running into that
only thing i have is time
wow
lucky dog
new lucky dog you
time winner did not deserve that
um
i didn't see i didn't really find a way
to tame that night
night on c4 my knight was
on his back foot
let's try french
meg ir fan
first time playing this
player
wow that's unusual
offering a queen exchange
i'm cool with that out of the french
um
let's try to close it up i should be
able to get in b4 can't be stopped
because of the pin the timing is not
right to get the rook away
but uh
what do i want to say here let's maybe
close it up even further and go hunting
after this pawn
okay i'll return
yeah that's a that's a good try
for sure
because otherwise i think i just pick up
that pawn and then there's nothing
i need to square for my king this should
be a pretty cozy home
i like how i'm playing this
okay
um
didn't see that one
yikes
i'm in trouble
wow
i could just simplify
toast
it's me
oh man my rook on h2 my mark on a2
gourley again
all right
and i'm extinguished on top of it all
all right we're going to launch some
pawns on the king's side
i just dropped this
oh boy
this is not gonna go good i gotta change
it up
the queen is way too good
improve my king
and my night and eventually flush their
night away
with the baby
the baby stuff let's just um am i
setting myself up for h4
maybe
just protect eventually we flush this
guy back they're shuffling
their knights out of play now
now my king comes over here
they have any tricks
could take because of the pin
and i'm winning this night
have some time in the tank
it's just trade
of this good square as well
pile up on the back rank okay they
resigned was that their first
loss think it's their first loss yeah
they're really cruising there
okay i'm at 10 i've had one four
that's not going to cut it
not even close
okay alcatel
we got a mover
we could try to go fishing but
yeah
um
all right i guess we go for the queen
exchange
whoa
we're going a little too fast there
i just want to trade
i should have captured that night first
let's kick the knight before my knight
is flushed
yeah now this is a perfect square for
the bishop king and d7
i need to castle here or i could give
the check okay they resigned
so where am i at okay another two
next game
important
dr vega punk
not our first time playing game number
two
let's flush him back
actually he didn't have to go back he
had a choice there
all right i'm close to having a depth
death grip over this position i got it
no f5
so this should turn
in my favor
there's no way into this square because
of the space advantage
those space invader pawns and the play
on the queen side where i have space
there shouldn't really be much happening
i could have maybe
tried to stop b5
their only trick here is this uh
sacrifice on g4 but that
that shouldn't be working
i'm gonna keep some pressure on b5 this
is a this is their main struggling piece
i'll trade should really favor me even
in a
major piece less position
ideally what i would like to have happen
okay
is uh
is a light square bishop exchange
i've done well to uh stir up some
trouble
ready for bishop c4
i'll take him out
light square control
okay we're getting this pawn
okay
um that actually got a little more
complicated than i would have liked i i
really didn't want to see any sacrifice
at all
okay meg
meg again
this was the the killer defeat i gotta
gotta do better this time around 10
minutes to
go okay
things should be pretty smooth
development wise i have this nice
long-term target
and pins we're going to have
um
i'll take straight away
am i falling for tricks
i want to exchange first this
these these pawns are all very weak
king up
actually why is my king going in this
direction
check and then take like this
rook is doing a good job
should just be able to vacuum up a bunch
of pawns now
vacuum rook check here would have been
nice
and then take
i want to make sure this guy's gone
playing this one well
should have been much cleaner
much much cleaner
we'll get it done though
cut the king off
should be clean from here
little stalemates
okay eight minutes to go hat one two
three oof
flawless
doubled up
32.
i know i i thought i had 16 there that
was i guess a slight delay
with giving me the four so i'm three
full games back
is the game gonna finish here and make
it paired no
i need some quick winners
could try for h2
h2 is officially shut down
i like i like this square right here for
my knight
it's a pretty good square
queen exchange
i guess
i want f6 in
remove this uh pivot square
and now i can maybe do something with
the g file
could activate my rook
okay
there's now a trick here
for caroni on e3 they're in the tank
not quite sure what this move is doing
they could they could probably take here
mine f3
maybe this was the more correct thing to
do now we flush the knife back
one move punch
i'm just trying to make some fast moves
i'm anticipating this is
going to be a time when it is six
minutes to go that guy did yeah
doesn't have fire but still got two this
game ending in a draw 24 34 up ten
three games i think i could get in
will they be three w's though
stop night before
open h file
queen side castle
probably a little crazy to go queenside
castle this knight simply has to return
now
could work on these weaknesses over here
the queen side weaknesses
for starters let's rule out these two
minors
could expand
drop that guy in there with check
i could grab that guy
on the rook
and
okay let's defend the a3 pawn
that bishop is really
too good
i could have pushed that would have been
that would have been better
my king needs to uh come over here to
assist
now he could get rolling
hopefully
broke up and then b5 no
they're making it annoying
king comes over
okay i got a pawn
much cleaner now
okay
he resigned back to tournament four
minutes to go 28 36 isn't first
it's going to be tricky to even get on
the podium we'll see
next game
all game is important from here
a little room for air in the 27 minute
tournaments
one loss maybe and get that second loss
in there
you're close to cooked
african farouja
all right
they're still in a pin
to be careful about the
knight tricks here
let's hit the weakest point
if the knight there i'll i'll take like
this i think this is a
i think i can restrict their dark square
bishop it should not be
an issue and now this knight has a
forever
outpost they should be angling for a
night on d6
i had a fork there
but i actually valuable value this
knight is worth maybe er
rook right here
maybe i get their night
okay
that guy's gone
i want this knight
knight on c4
almost there
i really would
prefer not to go like this
like
yeah i need to keep control over this
me a problem here
fork
all right can i get one more game in
first is out of
reach and yeah let's see if i could just
hang to hang onto third
um is he in a game
the four guy
this will be tough to even get in
i'll take with the queen
keep it a bit more opened
okay
queen's gonna get scared around
let's do it like this
pull the knight away
on the queen twice
that was a really stupid way to do it
for me
they had a way to
yeah that was not a clean
approach to winning a piece
27 seconds
two different forks
there and f2
that's me
ah
all right time is up
i
am gonna hang on a third okay ten
seconds left only
i'll take it
not the greatest start
good games all
fun as usual
flies by hat123
gourley well done
from we don't know
usa second
there's your page one
let's look at the top 50.
who else was playing
top 50.
10 or more for top 50
27 minute
okay
you